[Music]
all right you can hear me and see me fun
happy Star Wars day everybody may the
fourth be with you as I said on the
first one which the sound is choppy I've
been a big star Wars fan for years been
a big part of my life man Star Wars was
my first hardcore fan too my fandom
Snoopy I was big fan of when I was a kid
of course Batman I was big fan of in the
comic books and of DC and Marvel and
Spiderman was my jam but those
characters all existed before I existed
so I came into a world where they were
there it was like playing with your
brother's toys Star Wars came into a
world that I existed in and I was
already seven when Star Wars that was
six on the verge of seven when Stowers
happened and it felt like it was made
for us it felt like oh my god this is
our so it was different it was the first
real fandom where I had you know that
that this is mine and we all spoke the
same language those of us that liked it
and that was the whole world and stuff
mostly kids so you know it was I was big
old spider Whitman it was always big
feature in my childhood I got to join we
were poor but my mom got me a membership
to the Star Wars fan club look at that
man look at you can see the number
please don't steal my [ __ ] identity
in the Star Wars fan club the official
Star Wars fan club and then I liked it
so much I made the unofficial Star Wars
fan club junior man look at that so I go
deep with this [ __ ] this is who sent it
to me they sent it from a magical place
called Mount Morris Illinois anybody
ever heard of it anybody lived there
that's where the Star Wars fan club sent
their [ __ ] at and they would send stuff
like stickers and whatnot so I love the
Star Wars movies when I was a kid so
much saw it brought him into my
adulthood when I started making movies
and clerks there's a Death Star
contractors scene in mall rats there's
Silent Bob trying to move the cigarette
with his mind
in chasing amy Hooper's whole speech in
the beginning at the comic-con about
gentrification Jay and Silent Bob strike
back I actually got to lightsaber fight
with Mark Hamill with Luke Skywalker
himself and my parents were there on set
and as you know we were between takes
mark on his full cock-knocker regalia
talked to my parents and said to my mom
you must be so proud like oh my lawyer
this must make you so proud look what
your son's doing man and he I don't know
how it came out I know if it was the
maybe it was him going like the eat must
Ben it must be so I think it was this
yes it must be so weird to see him go
from a kid to all this and my mom said
not really so weird when he was a kid he
played with Luke Skywalker action
figures and no she said when he was a
kid he played with your action figure
and now he just plays with you so I got
you know obviously big fan and it showed
up in that work showed up later on in
Jay and Silent Bob reboot ler character
named Millennium milli Millennium Falcon
but in Jane salvo check back Carrie
Fisher played are none I think her exact
credit is the hairy bush none but maybe
not on IMDB but in any event huge day
for me because I was and still remain a
massive Carrie Fisher fan not just like
oh she was Princess Leia although that's
what I was introduced to her Star Wars I
liked her and of course very much but
Empire Strikes Back like that's why I
fell in love with her all that romantic
[ __ ] with her and Han Solo and stuff and
then I've watched all of her movies
under the rainbow i watch i remember
when i watched the Paul Simon and Simon
& Garfunkel concert in the park because
I thought they might cut to her in a
crowd because she was going out with
Paul Simon at the time so I was a big
fan I had Carrie Fisher pictures
everywhere look at this see this [ __ ]
galactically yours Carrie Fisher and it
looks like you know it was like [ __ ]
handwritten for years I was like
she sent me a [ __ ] handwritten
picture and then years later I send away
for another one hoping to get another
and they sent me the exact same one so
you know naturally it was a form thing
but I have that and a frame next to my
bed grown up at Star Wars posters very
Princess Leia oriented I had the Empire
Strikes Back sheets I told Carrie Fisher
when we met I was like I had Empire
Strikes Back cheez-it Princess Leia all
over am I to tell you what happened to
those sheets and she was like oh I know
so meeting Carrie and having Carrie in
the movie was a big [ __ ] deal and in
order to be in the movie Blues Brothers
Jordan Lee pointed out I loved during
the Blues Brothers you know we made the
same offer to extend the same offer we
extended to everyone who was in the cast
which was his scale you know very
minimum to be in the movie nobody got
rich Carrie didn't want the money
Carrie instead asked our casting
director I want the production to buy me
this pair of antique beaver chairs that
I've had my eye on and so you know we
were like I it was like five grand for
these two chairs that beaver design and
then when I finally met her on set I was
like can't thank you enough for doing
this I said but beaver chairs you got to
explain that to me she's like well I
just wanted to get these chairs but I
didn't want to spend the money myself so
if you guys bought him that made it easy
she's gone but also I thought it was
very appropriate currency exchange for
this movie beaver chairs oh my god so
Carrie Fisher and I after that flick
would email all time we got friendly and
stuff and not like every week or
whatever but periodically every other
month we exchange emails and stuff she
was witty as [ __ ] acerbic is [ __ ] a
wonderful writer even her emails even if
they were short or long they were
memorable so we had that kind of
relationship brain sugar I think was her
address email address in any event I had
access to her and vice versa I also had
access of course to my message board the
view skew message board of USQ calm our
old website which still exists but the
message board doesn't and it was a big
whiteboard that looked like Reddit and
been around since like late 95 that's
when we had the that's when we started
Ming created Ming Chen from comic book
men created the viewcube message board
and so somebody on the message board and
this would be I was living in California
and I moved out here February 2002 so
this would be somewhere between 2002 and
2005 CBD cigarettes so someone on the
message board said hey man I went to a
show last night Carrie Fisher show with
her mom I guess Carrie and her mom we're
doing Q&A tours or whatever for show and
at the end there was a QA they said and
a journey Q&A somebody asked about Jay
and Silent Bob strike back and Carrie
[ __ ] on it you know she was just like
that movie piece of [ __ ] whatever or
something like that said some you know
nothing but walling and I was bummed out
so I was like what the [ __ ] man like
[ __ ] I thought we were buds and you
know since I had a rebelled dress I
emailed her and I was just like what the
[ __ ] I thought we were buds I was like
you know if you didn't want to be in the
movie you didn't have to be in the movie
like you know why would you go around
slag in the movie I don't go around slag
and you all this you know guilt inducing
[ __ ] layered on thick like how could you
do this to me Princess Leia and this
ladies and gentlemen is the point of our
story today this is the greatest gift
that Star Wars ever gave me and mind you
I got a lot of [ __ ] out of Star Wars man
I got the you know all the references in
the movie my whole career my movies are
tied in the Star Wars Death Star
contractor scene and clerks was the most
talked about scene when the movie came
out without star wars maybe I got
nothing right that all being said and
I've had and it would gave me a happy
childhood
we were poor very poor but my mom would
still save money from my dad's paycheck
and buy me Star Wars action figures and
that meant the world and stuff because
that was the currency of childhood I got
a lot out of stores this this is this is
the single greatest thing I got
starwars a piece of advice from Carrie
Fisher not even a piece of advice piece
of wisdom wizened piece of carrie
fisher's brain sugary mind was this she
read my email I guess she wrote back to
me in a relatively timely fashion and
she said Oh Kevin did you fall prey to
the Internet and then she wrote about
how like you're like me you get up on
stages you tell stories you try to be
funny when you're up there you say
anything if the audience attaches to it
and laughs you go with it I was just
being funny she's going you and I are
friends you know how I feel about you
you know what I think about your movie
why would you let something somebody on
the internet said change all that and
then she dropped this truth bomb right
my lap and I still use this today this
is a piece of knowledge that changed my
life and it wouldn't have happened
without Star Wars because without Star
Wars I wouldn't know I'm Carrie Fisher
and she wouldn't been in Jay and Silent
Bob strike back here you go Carrie
Fisher goes sometimes you have to spin
that microscope around because the thing
you're looking at isn't as big as you
think it is
that came from Carrie Fisher herself man
now she may have just been like [ __ ] you
got me it was a truth bomb but
regardless that is a piece of advice
that I still adhere to today when [ __ ]
looks bleak when the whole world when it
feels like the whole world hates my
movie or whatever the [ __ ] and [ __ ] my
movie when it just like when I read the
news about you know in a covet era where
I'm like nothing will ever be that same
I remember the wizened words of my good
friend and and one time crush Carrie
Fisher sometimes you guys spin the
microscope around sometimes that thing
you're looking at isn't as big as you
think it is as you're oh it's very tiny
it just looked a big cuz I was all the
scrutiny and whatnot so there it is man
genius piece of advice from a genius
lady I miss her
she was very cool she was in this very
house Princess Leia was in my house one
time we had a poetry event for my kids
private school yes it's just as bougie
it's a [ __ ] sounds lights how I
opened the shark I was the emcee and I
was like thank you all for donating to
that most needy of causes you know
private school children there's a poetry
event for Poetry Month which I think was
February and we did as a fundraiser from
school so we held it in my house and we
fit like I guess 100 200 people in the
in the house and we had cool people
including the great Stanley red God God
woke his poem as well as The Raven in
two separate events Johnny Rotten was
here Eva Longoria is crazy the amount of
people that we had read and poetry but
one of them was Carrie Fisher so I was
getting up in between each poetry thing
going hey thanks bye now the next one is
this being the emcee
Carrie Fisher I grab me between intros
well somebody was up and she was like I
didn't [ __ ] know you were gonna be
joking around and [ __ ] cursing and
[ __ ] like that she's like I brought like
a serious poem to read I thought this
was a serious poetry event I was like do
whatever you want with your time though
I mean I'm just up there you know trying
it everyone's drinking I'm trying to
keep things light and stuff so yeah like
don't don't be feel any pressure you
don't have to you know be like you don't
have to be anything serious they're just
happy to see you and so she goes well
I'm gonna change by my approach that's
alright and then she got up when I
introduced her as a glaze a gentleman
you know Carrie Fisher and she gets up
and her and her thing was this she goes
okay I had had something prepared but
then you know I saw that we're doing a
comedy show and so you know I thought
what I brought was kind of silly and and
so you know I was racking my brain for
poetry that I could do instead at the
last minute anything that I know and she
said an Arthur Conan Doyle said of
Sherlock Holmes that periodically he
would clear his mind of old useless
information to make way for new
data and she said so I've always tried
to practice that and I've always tried
to clear my mind of old information she
said but there's one piece of
information that has been in my brain
forever that it's a part of my childhood
in my life and will always be with me no
matter what I do and it goes a little
something like this
and then she bent down and she won
general Kenobi
years ago you fought with my father in
the Clone Wars and she did the entire
help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my only
hope speech and I believe she did it a
version of this in her live show wishful
drinking like years later I can't lay
claim to this but I'm pretty sure it
might have been born in that moment
because the [ __ ] crowd went nuts the
moment she was like general Kenobi and
you know she delivered it then this kind
of like I can't believe I still know
this and 200 people like and if I know
any creative any creative you know who
sees a moment in life they they mark it
down use that later on so I remember for
wishful drinking there was a moment that
was very similar and I was like never
got to ask her regardless I didn't take
an authorship I'm just saying she did it
here in this house she did that speech
in my house the speech that I saw her
given the hallway in that movie space
hallway years ago to a little garbage
can robot and captured my imagination
was a 6 / 7 year old she did it right
here in this house that is my Star Wars
day of memory man happy happy Star Wars
day kids may the fourth be with you go
check out that Kevin Smith Club comm if
you're into this kind of stuff I did a
whole Star Wars thing there today for my
show wake-and-bake but on Star Wars day
since we're all probably stuck inside
use this to take a journey back into a
happy childhood memory your favorite
Star Wars movie are all the [ __ ] Star
Wars movies watch all the Star Wars is
men I remember when I was a kid I wanted
to go to Grumman
Chinese Theater so bad down the street
from where I live now but I lived in New
Jersey done because r2d2 and c3po and
Darth Vader put their footprints in the
cement in the forecourt of the Grauman's
Chinese Theater and I went there as a
picture of me and my brother kneeling in
front of it it's up on my Instagram my
old man you know was showing me all the
prints ago and this is this one there's
this one beyond the ones I knew like
this Myrna Loy she's dead now you know
this is Jimmy Durante remember he had
the big nose he pushed his nose into the
spin isn't that funny there's Clint
Eastwood you know there's their prints
not the real people and now I loved
Hollywood and entertainment and [ __ ]
like that we didn't have the internet so
you couldn't engage with it as much as
people do now but mall man goes to me
you know he says that stupid [ __ ] you
say to a kid meant nothing you know
wasn't like I'm gonna plant a seed but
just something nice to say there was kid
he goes maybe you'll be here someday and
40 years later after he said that me and
J put our handprints and our footprints
in the cement at Grauman's Chinese
Theatre we're not right next to our 2d -
and c3po but can't believe we're even
[ __ ] there man sometimes you could
love it thanks so much kids that it
infects your life informs the rest of
your life and stuff and even though as
much as I love it like you know some
people like don't you want to [ __ ]
make us star wars I don't have enough
talent to make a Star Wars I barely have
enough talent to make a Kevin Smith
movie you think you want to [ __ ] see
me be on the camera of any Star Wars Ian
thing some things I just want to still
love and appreciate as a fan from a
distance like I have my whole life and
stuff Star Wars Marvel movies any comic
book movies and stuff like that that's I
like that that's I like that I can
reference it I like that I could meet
the people involved and stuff I've been
in a Star Wars I was in rise of
Skywalker walking by in the background
my voice is in force awakens all these
tangential things are wonderful but I
don't need to like be the puppet master
poem strings and [ __ ] like that
directing the Star Wars or anything
like
some [ __ ] I'm just happy to still enjoy
you know if I want to ruin a movie I can
ruin one of mine but Star Wars that's
where I'm a kid again
like that's where I kick back in a
theater and oh my god
it's just like when I was a kid and my
dad was sitting next to me and it's
everything man Star Wars is love
trademark Disney in any event may the
fourth be with you all happy Star Wars
day don't forget two things that Kevin
Smith club.com or more importantly like
our good general Leia Organa told me
years ago in the person of the real
person of Carrie Fisher spin that
microscope around sometimes that's
important in life
hey the fourth be with you everybody
you